la polémique de sort c'est d'aller chez
les marseillais n'en finit pas d'enfler
hier soir c'est magali berda habitués de
nos plateaux et agents de carla moreau
qui venait livrer sa version des faits y
avait des notes audio qui ont été faites
car là ne renie pas ses notes audio
l'avouer donc a pas de montage elle
précise cependant que carla aurait
enregistré ces audio sous la menace
karl a dit depuis samedi matin qu'elle
l'a fait sous influence une sombre
histoire de racket qui aurait été
orchestrée par la voyante à laquelle
aurait fait appel car la danaé ce n'est
pourtant pas ce que déclaré son père en
début de semaine lors d'un live
instagram où il est accusé carla d'user
de sorcellerie depuis ses 17 ans durant
15 minutes il a tenu des propos très
durs envers sa fille qu'il juge
entièrement responsable mais dans cette
affaire aux multiples rebondissements
qui dit vrai l'acharnement au tour de
carla et il injuste ce soir son père
raphaël moreau est avec nous alors avant
d'avoir le témoignage le cri du coeur de
son papa d'abord j'aimerais savoir
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous de
cette affaire gilbert des jets que vous
avez des informations encore
oui alors j'ai essayé d'abord on dit
qu'une enquête ça tourne autour d'une
enquête ouverte par ce que il y aurait
une première voyante qui a balancé qui a
balancé aujourd'hui sur ces réseaux
sociaux snap chat un chat de 22 minutes
où cette voyante en accuse une autre et
elle prononce des mots forts elle dit
que tout ça est sur fond de cocaïne
voire de cambriolage qui aurait forcé
les candidats de télé réalité à s'en
aller ce que j'aurai une affaire de
racket et on a parlé on l'a dit ici
d'une enquête de la police judiciaire de
marseille
moi j'ai appelé la police judiciaire de
marseille je suis tombé sur la sécurité
publique à marseille j'ai appelé le
parquet de marseille pour le moment je
n'ai aucun retour
concernant une information judiciaire
ouverte mais je continue à enquêter
je ne suis pas certain je ne suis pas
certain qu'il y ait vraiment une enquête
de police ouverte sur cette affaire
je continue à prendre des pincettes là
dessus je pense que les histoires de
règlements de comptes et de sorcellerie
sont vraies est ce qu'il ya une enquête
de police autour de trafic de cocaïne ou
prise de cocaïne dans des soirées et
cambriolages orchestrée autour de
candidats télé réalité il est forcé à
l'exil à dubaï ne suit pas ça mais dans
un instant droit le père de carla donc
celle qui est au coeur de cette
polémique qui sera avec nous qu'ils
soient
lancé un appel à sa fille on avait vu la
vidéo de son papa qui était voilà
c'était là voilà il est énorme il était
pas il n'était pas complètement avec
elle mais là il souhaite lui lancé un
appel
gilles verdez juste avant ne pas parler
de cette histoire de sorcellerie
oui parce que pour nous et pour les
téléspectateurs franchement il a plein
qui vont animer qu'est ce que c'est que
cette connerie mais vous y croyez
vraiment et si vous dites qu'ils sont
tous sous l'emprise de la sorcellerie
oui alors c'est à dire alors expliqué
pour nos téléspectateurs bu beaucoup de
candidats de télé réalité comme tous les
gens allaient voir des voyantes pour
connaître leur avenir mais il ya une
dérive notamment dans la télé réalité
c'est qu'il ya quelques années des
candidates de télé réalité ont été voir
non plus des voyantes mais ce qu'on
appelle des sorcières c'est à dire des
gens qui jettent des sorts voilà un
bâillon soit ou pas elle travaille
ensemble
c'est incroyable a donc elle travaille
ensemble absolument donc on jette un
sort à quelqu'un pour l'envoûter pour le
ruiner et pour briser son couple ses les
deux cas des faits puis retour the nato
les deux principales raisons
voilà le couple et la carrière
professionnelle donc argent il est donc
beaucoup beaucoup ont voulu contrer
l'envoûtement dont ils ont vu qu'ils
étaient victimes cru il ya une dérive
vraiment je peux vous l'affirmer dans la
télé réalité il ya énormément de gens
qui lancent des sorts à d'autres pour
les ruiner pour avoir le premier rôle
pour casser le rival pour casser un
couple etc
donc je n'utilise pas les
responsabilités sur cette histoire là
mais la sorcellerie
oui existe dans parmi les candidates et
les candidats de télé-réalité vraiment
il faut que ça s'arrête parce que ça
prend des proportions incroyables
moyenne vraie question qui se pose en ce
moment c'est celle de la potentielle
exclusion de carla des marseillais il ya
une info qui est sorti à quelques heures
la production des marseillais aurait
décidé de la retirer ou du moins du
moins la gommer au maximum des épisodes
et en ce moment il ya le hashtag boycott
marseillaise qui a une vraie révolte sur
twitter contre cette décision de gommer
carla des épisodes alors que la sphère
n'a pas été totalement juger ça c'est la
première info et la deuxième chose c'est
que j'ai contacté des candidats des
marseillais qui affirme selon certaines
personnes aient marqué qu'elle ne serait
plus dans les saisons ce qui est un
énorme manque à gagner pour elle parce
qu'on en parlait hier elle aurait
dépensé des fortunes
dans cette sorcellerie on sait que les
influenceurs est tant mieux pour eux
gagnent très bien leur vie aujourd'hui
faut pas oublier que ses revenus ils
viennent certes d'instagram mais la base
de ça c'est leur popularité leur
notoriété qu'ils ont obtenus grâce à
leur passage dans des émissions
auxquelles elle joue gros elle pourrait
quitter les marseillais alors on
connaissait la voyante danaï voilà et la
voyante de carla qui est celle par qui
le scandale est arrivé
mais une autre voie nantes vient de
faire son entrée dans le jeu elle
s'appelle warda une vidéo dans laquelle
elle confirme que carla serait bien
victime d'une escroquerie
regardez j'ai des audio qui dure plus de
trois heures j'ai dit bien plus de trois
heures avec des preuves avec des photos
des dossiers des gardes à vue
bien sûr c'est pas sur moi les gardes à
vue c'est sur dana et il ya eu du racket
il ya eu des menaces envers cette jeune
carla alors c'est pas de l'acharnement
sur danone je prends ballet rope est
d'elle c'est elle qui s'est acharné sur
moi j'ai des audio fouette un award à
moi y'a personne qui m'est un oui j'ai
essayé d'appeler le l'avocate de damas
et qui aurait eu des démêlés en justice
mais pour le moment on n'arrive pas à
savoir exactement
est ce que c'est un règlement de comptes
entre voyante sorcière ou est ce que
réellement il ya des choses
en tout cas on attend les documents est
ce qui est très particulier c'est que
elle dit j'ai tout enregistrer oui mais
juste ces gens-là enregistrerait n'est
une consultation
oui parce que quand vous allez voir une
voyante jamais jamais c'est enregistrez
vous en tant que cliente vous pouvez
enregistrer la conversation et encore
vous lui demandez mais jamais ça
n'existe pas et elle vous fait pas
penser à quelqu'un à quelqu'un la voix
si ceux qui la voient quand même neuf
ans tandis qu' à notre ami de sylvie
ortega il a la même voix je n'allais pas
partout il en est avec eux le père de
carla tout fraîchement si un appel à sa
fille raphaëlle qui est avec nous en
facetime
merci raphaël d'être là merci beaucoup
bonsoir raphaël et les amis témoins
voilà alors bien c'est super merci
cyrine monde en tous les cas elle
raphaël qui nous regardent qui nous
regardent très souvent à qui je fais un
gros bisou raphaël déjà merci
je déclare que c'est super merci
beaucoup alors je vous en syrie l'un
pour moi de façon j'ai aujourd'hui
toujours régné beaucoup attaqué parce
que déjà
j'aurais aimé ça fait longtemps que je
pense à vous parce que je voulais que
vous habitiez sur votre plateau se
serait pas passé comme ça ne veut jamais
dans la vie
nous avons été mous je vous le dis mais
ça sera ses autres marques alors vous
parlez de votre fille raphaëlle car là
vous avez envie de la rencontrer vous
avez envie de lancer un un cri du coeur
ce soir mais si c'est non non non ça
c'est important c'est ça le plus
important nous on n'est pas là parce que
oui eh ben moi une façon je vais vous
dire ça va commencer passage à niveau
sur le coeur parce que moi j'aime ma
fille c'était l'entente series vous avez
des enfants jetés comme un temps de
parole raphaël et bien j'ai pas vue
depuis sept ans depuis cette histoire là
où malheureusement cette voyante a dit
certains devant de prendre les chèques à
son papa et moi dangereuse dame j'ai pas
lu mais c'est pas grave du tout parce
que j'en ai pas du toit va pire c'est
moi et visiter pas super père c'était
pas super père voilà à vrai dire même un
mauvais père parce que j'ai vu que
jamais voir dans l'école de la vie
j'essayais pour moi d'être bon père et
je veux être un bon père et j'arrêtais
aussi j'avais des problèmes d'alcool est
arrêtée depuis admis à l'oral
ce que vous avez vu hier à bercy pas moi
j'ai pas vu du tout c'est tout c'est
l'appel que j'ai un père qui voit sort
et voilà si je bave pas là ici en photo
et caméras je suis désolé mais j'ai
passé pas mal du tout un passé pas mal
du tout rafael vous inquiétez pas tout
va bien raphaël juste vous n êtes pas
vous dire aussi que je leur avais dit
avant que vous pouviez plein de question
pour moi c'est très difficile parce que
ça décolle bâtiments abîmés emma et j'ai
perdu toute ma famille et j'ai perdu ma
fille que j'aime et que j'ai pu te
vraiment le très vite vite qu'il dit là
bas ça me tue le temps de revenir ça
fait mal
non mais non mais non mais alors afin
non va recommencer du tout moi je vous
dis moi je préfère avoir votre
témoignage et vous me disiez c'est plus
important que vous me disiez vous aviez
envie de revoir votre ville vous n'avez
pas vue depuis sept ans carla et je
pense que le plus ce qui serait le plus
important pour elle je pense que ce
serait le plus beau et raphaël peut pas
parler de ça je veux pas si vous voulez
que votre gauche pendant les petites
manies doit finir je laime cours à temps
mais ce qu'est ce qui s'est passé
pourquoi vous l'avez pas vue depuis sept
ans kalakh
qu'est ce qui s'est passé eh bien je
vais vous dire tout simplement
elle est allée voir c'est au voyage
c'est qui vient sortir d'actifs
vous savez ma fille c'est une fille moi
que j'ai j'ai essayé dans tous les cas
d'avis yeux d'avoir garé à voir je suis
très siège est toujours faire très
attention tous les vendredis au bal du
poisson j'ai toujours baigné la fille
j'ai toujours fait essayer parce que
j'ai grandi avec la filiale ceux ci sont
bas j'ai gré j'ai eu pendant beaucoup
d'années avec ce marin habité en fin
d'année ensemble après une séparation je
la voyais régulièrement tous les quinze
jours et après la vie qu'avec moi avant
de partir dans les bars et y est et là
j'ai senti quelqu'un dre beats avec moi
car entre 15 et 17 ans tim bug je vous
écoute cyril non mais raphaël on a été
un petit peu coupé juste ma file
qu'est-ce que moi on sait ça vous
interroger sur la voyante ça qu'est ce
que vous voulez dire à carla ce soir
j'aurais bien car leur ranch comme si tu
es mon bébé tu mentionnes qui va la vie
depuis qu'elle est partie des personnes
de bâle ville parce que tu veux battre
ici tu vas vis et combi si nos banquiers
de loulo mais je voulais pas parce que
parce que tu vois j'ai je voulais pas te
mettais pendant sept ans j'ai pas vu se
dit la vérité car là c'est que tu as vu
que je buvais joue les jamais que si
nous voyons de quoi me voir c'est que
quand sharon pour moi et tu as tout
supporter pour moi mais ça c'est toi de
et je ne compte pas le gars là et je me
pardonne
me pardonne et s'affiche dans la france
entière que je suis quelqu'un de pudique
et tu vois si les gens auront envie
d'évoquer les chroniqueurs ça arrive ne
permet pas du site papa ou aux îles à
peine capable par des fentes et moi
j'avais cette boule aux éditions en plus
mais ma fille un jour c'est ma ville
mais les choses allèrent votre fille
raphaëlle moi ce que je pense j'espère
que cette histoire sa tête est pas mal
pour un bien et que ça va vous permettre
de retrouver votre fille car là vous
allez pouvoir vous pour retrouver et
parce que je suis sûr que carlao si elle
a envie de retrouver son papa et que
alors je veux vous expliquer aussi la
coupure de ses 7 ans alors je vais vous
dire ça m'avait vraiment plaisant betis
tchèque jeudi c'est accablant
j'ai lui coûtent deux fois il ya c'est
quoi cette histoire des fonds
nathaël c'est quoi cette histoire de
chèque l'été la noyade et a coûté
imaginez vous un album 17 ans moi j'ai
lu et c'est un gars là je vais vous le
dire je la connais parfaitement s'il
voit qu'il est le père c'est une équipe
qui est trop gentil et brega chalon la
gtl et rouge 1-0 comme ça elles vont
n'importe quel d'honorer tous si tu ne
les utilisaient pour vous c'est pour ça
qu'elle a aucun sou sur le sur la banque
mais c'est pas ça s est fait embobiner
moi je vous le dit c'est partir si ses
maxis à messieurs donc elle est allée
voir s'ils voyagent sur l'échec c'est je
peux vous l'assurer et par contre ce que
je peux vous assurer les gardes à toute
la france
je vous garantis qu'à l'avenir elle
voudrait faire de mal à personne a
drummer je vous jure c'est pas une vie
qu'il veut faire du mal mais peut-être
cela populaire et y est certaine ce que
cette fable ii 7 ans mme royal vous
savez donc pas de 17h moi je suis
cuisinier
j'apprends à des petits jeunes
l'apprentissage de la cuisine c'est
facile
elle a profité de leur pire elle a dit
son point faible moi j'avais de l'argent
à les toits comme donc je me rendais pas
compte qu'ils vous voyez graphiste c'est
tout pour moi puisque j'avais si tout
pour elle vous voyez c'est elle que tout
perforé moi j'ai jamais mais raphaël
aide à payer la voyante avec l'argent
exactement
la voyante à rien c'est avec des chèques
de sonde voilà c'est ça lui est voulu gm
veut pas du tout parce que delta est
toute en filets les six mois je n'étais
pas bien sûr et moi ap rafael est ce que
vous êtes fiers de votre fille de ce
qu'elle a fait de son parcours de paix
c'est un mois d'affilée mais je suis
hyper violent ma vie vous savez chers
qu'aux poids chaque jour vous avez voix
de chaque zone l'adjointe de gueule
outils et allez me dire oui je dis oui
de pierre et modèles savoir ce que je
fais alors j'ai dit oui et oui tu y es
tu me dis je suis tellement rigide qui
est qu'il est là dans le magicien le 24
à issy tout ça mais comme elle est belle
elle magnifie et moi j'adore mullany de
dire je t'aime de désir mais vous savez
pâtissier la petite bonne quinzaine est
allé voir sa taille les combattants de
cette charte est et j'ai des balles
qu'ils veulent c'est de perdre à cannes
quimper mange tout comme magali bertin
et je m'excuse de le lay d'atr c'est pas
que d'avoir mal parier parce que je sais
pas si elle n'avait qu'un mot ciel est
adéquat
ça me regarde pas je ne suis pas de tir
mais moi je dis pas non mais non on vous
demande pas en tout cas que raphaël
merci pour votre cri du coeur joie se
trouve pas voilà retrait à savoir plus
et karl sera avec nous lundi et je pense
que le message de son papa va lui faire
bien plaisir en tout cas merci enfin la
colère un atteint et on vous reprend
parce que oui raphaël j'aimerais
beaucoup syrienne quand vous êtes au top
et moi je vois plutôt ça t'aurait tous
les producteurs je le remercie rafael
dites moi si vous faites des gardois
tout le mal si vous payez fois un petit
cadeau que je puisse pas marcher ma
petite fille elle que ben arfa sait
jamais on va essayer de faire le plein
avant la fin je m'accroche je vois plus
depuis lundi
vous avez jamais lus table je recule au
foot à leur séquence à eux et ici je il
se concocter la figure et bouge repris
du poids pour essayer de l'embêter et
toute ma vie si tu es pas gonfler au
bout de ces temps ci que chaque fois je
vais crise y est parce que j avais tes
meubles à peine est il si j'ai pas vu
j'oubliais vous
je voulais qu'un moyen de perdre trois
peut-être parce que je suis amoureux de
barthié je laime et est malheureusement
j'étais pas là il demande d'ailleurs je
veux être là et c'est terrible d'être
été comme cela à cause de l'alcool chez
kiabi voulu voir toute ma vie je savais
qu'il y aurait eu des appels
je vais faire le maximum on va faire le
max l'appel pour vous faire ce beau
cadeau d'accord mou rafael
voici ma petite fille je l'aurais pour
bercy rappelle on va faire le maximum en
tout cas on va essayer d'organiser ça ça
serait un abus 1 voilà ça serait une
belle fin à cette histoire merci raphaël
d'avoir été là ces voiliers il ya un
dossier après apparemment familial quand
même ça va être compliqué entre son père
et sa fille je pense que oui on sait
qu'elle avait disparu pendant sept ans
et on essaie de l'aider on va essayer
d'arranger les choses que vous êtes très
perspicace en enquêteur lui prêter
attention
[Rires]
c'est notamment sur la plume un vrai
revirement de situation parce que 1,5 de
plus en plus de personnes prennent la
défense de carla son papa était assez
durs dans la première vidéo qu'il avait
posté là il prend sa défense est dit qu
il m est pareil jeudi à cette vraie
vague de soutien sur twitter les gens
n'ont pas envie qu'on juge la faire
avant qu'elle soit jugée